thank you all for coming back um so i am
going to actually first figure out how
this thing works and i'm going to talk
about some recent work that we've been
doing in my lab related to an ongoing
large project on the molecular causes of
complications of preterm birth so for
those of you who have never thought
about this um babies who are born early
are maybe not surprisingly at higher
risk of sort of every conceivable health
consequence under the Sun throughout
their lifetimes right with you know a
slightly elevated risk of everything um
and we don't have a very good
understanding of particularly why or
what predisposes an individual to
particular complications and even within
the period of time that they're in the
hospital right after they're born so
mostly they stay babies were born early
will stay in the hospital for some
number of weeks or months until they're
able to breathe on their own and eat on
their own and stay warm so they can go
home during that time period some of
them have relatively uncomplicated
course clinical courses some of them get
complications that put them an increased
risk for lifelong illnesses and so on
and we don't really understand why that
happens the kind of standard approach
from clinicians has been to focus a lot
on infection as a cause of these
disorders and complications and that
obviously plays a huge role either
infections they acquire in the hospital
or infections that they like internal
infections that cause them to deliver
early in the first place but that's not
the whole story it's becoming
increasingly clear that there may also
be genetic and genotypes that predispose
you to certain vulnerability that that
could be triggered by the insult of
being born early and being on a
respirator or you know maybe you have
that same genotype and you weren't
important early and you don't get some
of these complications and but you're
susceptible to things later in life for
the same reason so we're interested in
looking at some of those connections um
and because this is a network meeting
I'm going to focus on a particular
project that we're doing that looks at
network centrality in this context I'm
also going to talk a little about some
temporal modeling stuff at the end but
mostly I'll stick to the network things
right and so this is general concept
we're going to look at molecular
networks both protein interaction and
regulatory networks and this general
concept of centrality is pretty well
studied there are lots of ways to sort
of say how central a node is in a
network right so you can measure its
distance to all the other is sort of
average distance to everything else is
sort of how central you are I think look
at how connected all of its neighbors
are right we're going to look at the
notion of between this cent rally which
is also a common method basically it's
just looking at math for any node you're
looking at the average number of
shortest paths between all the other
pairs of nodes that go through that node
and you normalize them by the number of
pairs there are right so in a greeeeat
literary graph like this for any node
you and any other nodes V and W um
there's only one path between them right
so you're going to contribute either 0
or 1 to this some you know Emma lies by
all pairs of nodes and you can kind of
get to see that these values captured
the Nisshin centrality that you might
expect at least in a graph like this and
they do so in larger graphs what's more
interesting is that it's been shown that
this kind of centrality actually says
something about function in molecular
networks right so this is some work from
about 10 years ago from mark Christine's
love that basically demonstrated that
nodes with high fractional between this
which he's calling bottlenecks rather
they have high degree or low degree are
more likely to be essential proteins in
regulatory networks that are capturing
information flow from place to place so
that he did not find the same result in
protein-protein interaction networks
which i think is kind of interesting
because it's sort of suggesting that the
ways in which information moves in those
networks may be a little bit different
um right so this is old work but it does
show that this is a relevant concept I
should also point out actually that you
could do this
there's a related notion to between the
centrality called flow centrality right
and you could look instead of at
shortest paths you could look at all
she'll pads and look at flow this work
could be replicated with flow sensuality
and would probably be very similar our
stuff could be replicated with flow
centrality it would probably be very
similar we have not done yet yet so
there's also a related notion of group
centrality right which is the average
fractional between the centrality of all
the nodes in a group and this is again
work from a number of years ago what's
interesting about that in the concept
context of molecular networks is that
you can now use group centrality to
start to look at information moving
through groups of proteins or jeans all
right so you can begin to say well okay
if I have ah there we go if I have a
node here and a note here I'm looking at
the shortest paths between them there's
one of length 4 that goes through this
blue node and one of length 4 that goes
through this blue node and so together
the two of these are capturing some
notion of centrality for the shortest
paths between those particular red nodes
and then of course you'd average over
all pairs of possible red nodes in the
graph right so we actually want to take
this a step further and use this to
capture information flow in
disease-related networks so what does
that really mean well we spend a lot of
time in our lab looking at expression
data but the problem with the gene
expression data is that it tends to
capture downstream effects of diseases
right you know you're seeing maybe the
consequence genes that are expressed in
consequence of some symptom of something
that was caused by something else we
also have information and growing
amounts of information about disease
genes right there it's becoming easier
and easier to do jiwa studies people who
are doing lots of them publishing this
data not necessarily replicating it but
so we have lots of disease genes but
they may not be differentially expressed
so the question is whether we can look
at the flow of information from maybe a
disease gene to a differentially
expressed gene and find groups of things
that are functionally related that are
in some sense mediating this signal okay
what can that tell us about disease and
so that's what we looked at doing we're
calling this pathway centrality
um and we did all pair shortest paths
with these disease genes and
differentially expressed genes in a
Content experiment I'll show you so
first quitting I have to tell you about
is what are the groups that we're using
there are some people doing work on
finding or learning those groups but
that's another topic we're just going to
use set groups we're going to start with
go biological process terms because
everybody does this we're also going to
use terms from the mammalian phenotype
ontology so basically the mouse genome
database has I know everybody likes to
work in yeast because it's really well
studied but we're looking at people so
nice mouse or mice are actually a better
model mouse genome database has a lot of
information about vast numbers of mouse
mutants that have been characterized for
particular phenotypes that the mutants
exhibit map to the mammalian phenotype
ontology right so we're going to say a
gene that is in the MPO phenotype term
if there exists some mouse mutant that
has of that gene that has that phenotype
right and it may not be all mutants and
it may not be all strains and we're just
not worrying about that right now so
very simple way of pulling that together
and the data set we want to look at
we're particularly interested right now
in a complication called
bronchopulmonary dysplasia which i will
from now on called BPD so basically when
babies are born early if there early
enough their lungs are not mature enough
for them to breathe on their own they
are all on some kind of respiratory
support right and usually they may start
out on a ventilator and go to something
that's just airway pressure and then go
to oxygen and eventually by hopefully by
their due date if not significantly
earlier their breathing room air on
their own there is a subset of the
population for whom this doesn't happen
right there is a developmental delay in
the development of the respiratory
system things don't go properly and they
don't get off of assisted reproductive
therapy on schedule that's sort of the
definition of the diagnosis of BPD so
it's a very pragmatic definition it's
not molecular ly based in any way is
just like they you know they're not on
room area
um but those infants who may even go
home on oxygen often again grow up to
have more respiratory problems they're
more likely to have asthma they're
likely to get early onset forms of
emphysema and we don't know why they get
this we don't know what's happening so
we decided to look at these three
disorders from different life stages to
see if there's some things in common and
again we've seen some evidence in other
places that there's some hints that
there are some shared commonalities
between them right but asthma is
something that affects people at all
stages of life COPD typically affects
older people and so we have expression
data from blood in these cases and lung
epithelial cells in these cases we also
wanted to make sure that pathways that
are central in these datasets aren't
just central in every Network we look at
right so we picked a negative control we
had some data for down syndrome lying
around and we didn't expect either
inflammation or respiratory disease to
be a figure prominently in down syndrome
so we just use that all the disease
genes here are going to be the genes on
chromosome 21 where you have an extra
copy of those um and we have the
expression data is from second trimester
amniotic fluid so I need to say a little
about genes particularly where we got
them from and how they overlap we have
from some previous work on disease genes
data set looking at combining stuff from
huge as a database of basically pure
aided us results and omen so we picked
that did that for BPD when we did it for
asthma and copd we got so many more
genes like a thousands of thousand genes
or something because there are so many
gs studies and most of the stuff isn't
reproducible fortunately there are so
many gs studies that there are reviews
that focus on things that are
reproducible and so we picked those so
they're smaller sets from those what I
do want to say is there's a little bit
of overlap in the gene sets but by and
large the disease genes are pretty
distinct however the differentially
expressed genes are hugely distinct and
we use the same kind of methods and
analysis from the microarray studies
copd is RNA seek and we used whatever
the authors use
um regarding networks right we took
protein-protein interaction experimental
data out of string and got a network of
this size we also did a regulatory
network with some recent to encode data
that's something you know substantially
fewer edges although almost the same
size node set but one thing that's
important is that in a directed network
reach ability becomes an issue when
you're talking about shortest paths so
actually the network is noticeably
smaller than in the protein-protein
interaction case and we'll see what
impact that has on the results and the
last method thing I want to tell you
about is this concept of how do we know
what high between this really is what's
meaningful right so we can computer
between this score our thought was to
compare it to the between the score of a
random gene set of the same size and
when we did that this is kind of made up
a degree distribution data but it
captures the notion that i want to show
which is that if you're sampling
randomly from something like this you're
going to get a huge number of very low
degree jeans right our gene sets are
basically functionally characterized
genes that are actually bias towards
having higher degree in being more
central and so initially everything was
significant and that didn't seem very
compelling so we looked at some methods
of sampling based on degree matching and
so on but the simplest way we found to
address this is even easier to explain
that all of that and that gave us almost
the same result is looking at
significance by sampling from the two
core of the network right so we're just
going to find a maximal sub graph with
the degree at least two we're going to
do this by repeatedly removing nodes of
degree less than two and we do that
again and again until we can't do it
anymore and then we sample from this
thing so that gives us significance
levels and at the moment these are not
adjusted from multiple testing beyond
that to take the actual probabilities
with a grain of salt but at least the
rankings are definitely consistent right
so what do we find we actually find way
too many results to summarize in here
right there's a lot of stuff that comes
out of this for all the different data
sets
but the things that we see in common i
just want to give you some of the
flavors of what we're finding right so
the first thing we'd find out is that
you do see sort of the kinds of
inflammatory and immune system processes
that you would expect to be implicated
in all three of these prominent
disorders and you also see more specific
specific pathways being implicated I'm
going to come back and talk about
insulin receptor in a minute but I think
I won't go in there's like a story for
each of these lines and I can't stand up
here and tell you these stories all day
but i'll tell you a couple of them right
but we have you know so we get some more
specific mediating pathways when we
looked at the protein interaction at
works with the gene ontology results the
initial thing we found was that there
wasn't a lot significantly that was sort
of below our arbitrary point 05
threshold in all three disorders except
for very general terms involved in
transcription and most of those were
also involved in down syndrome or
significant in down syndrome that's not
so surprising because one of the things
we know about Down syndrome is that the
cells make a really valiant effort to
tamp down the fact that they have an
extra copy of that chromosome so you
don't actually get 1.5 fold up
regulation of all of those jeans they
like there's there's an effort to get
back to normal it doesn't quite succeed
but they're trying so that you know and
by the way on the previous slide most of
these except for these two are not
significant in the down syndrome control
so I felt pretty good about that but if
you relax this criterion in just a
little bit you start getting stuff out
that I think is significant I think the
reason for this it's a lot more
consistent with the protein-protein
networks with a few exceptions but I
think the reason for this is that we
have a much smaller network in practice
because of the directionality of it so I
just want to focus on a couple of
results in here one that I thought was
interesting is response to hypoxia
because you can certainly imagine that
baby is born early who aren't breathing
well are in a low oxygen environment
people with COPD potentially are not
getting enough oxygen people with asthma
if they're actually controlling it well
are probably not hypoxic right so this
is probably an average of people who are
and people who aren't and you get
something that's borderline
significant but not really down syndrome
though this isn't just a false positive
right this is one of the things we
really know about emilija about this
stage of development and Down syndrome
is that oxidative stress is playing a
major role they're not able to cope with
it properly so I actually believe that's
real the other thing I wanted to mention
since we're looking for mediators is NF
Kappa B as a mediator so this is known
in asthma and COPD it's actually
suggested as a therapeutic target
because it's known to be a mediator of
inflammation in those diseases it is not
known in BPD what the only thing I could
find that was it all suggestive is an
animal model that sort of suggests that
there is NF Kappa B mediated disruption
of airway development in response to
certain kinds of inflammation right so
it's possible this is a hypothesis we're
going to test in bronchopulmonary
dysplasia um let's see in the interest
of time I'm just say that the mammalian
phenotypes are a little bit more
specific pathways but um you know pretty
pretty much giving us similar kinds of
results interferon gamma is going to be
of interest a couple of the new things
that I wanted to focus on our this
insulin receptor thing we know insulin
plays a role in asthma and copd right we
know obesity diabetes are associated
with these in bronchopulmonary dysplasia
nobody-nobody studied this stuff as much
at the molecular level what we do know
about this again is that if you disrupt
a certain insulin receptor signaling in
rats they get disordered airway
development right so you can begin to
see a possible pathway and maybe a
possible treatment mechanism for
bronchopulmonary dysplasia if you know
which individuals are likely to be able
to be the ones to get it
interferon-gamma I'm also interested in
because there actually is a particular
snip that's been associated with two of
the three of these the third one doesn't
have anything about it in the literature
it hasn't as far as i can tell been
tested but we do have some collaborators
who are looking very closely for
variants that are associated with COPD
and they're very interested in this kind
of stuff so um another thing that we can
look at right so I was just
Down syndrome is a control but it turns
out this is interesting to in down
syndrome because we actually threw in
way too many disease genes right all we
really know about the disease genes is
you have a whole extra chromosome and
people have been arguing in literature
for years about partial deletions and
which parts of the chrome is that were
responsible for which of the down
syndrome phenotypes we actually have a
way of looking at this right so you can
look at let's say this low muscle tone
right we have no idea what on chromosome
21 gives people low muscle tone but we
can start to look at what are the
pathways that are actually going through
that set and see if we can figure out
what genes are involved in that and what
we could do about it so the other major
point that I wanted to make about all of
this is that right again I look at you
know you could look at each of these
sets of results and tell stories all day
but one of the things that falls out of
the bracha pulmonary dysplasia stuff is
there seemed to me a lot of gene sets
involved in sort of developmental delays
of various kinds um right so you can
understand why there's impaired lung
lobe morphogenesis that makes pretty
good sense it's less click the vascular
genesis thing I'm going to come back to
you there's a big debate about what role
that plays in BPD why is there delayed
bone ossification right this isn't a
bone disease does this make any sense it
kind of does because it seems from other
evidence that there is a general or
potentially there is a general
developmental phenotype that predisposes
infants to getting this complication we
know its associated with being small for
gestational age or short stature right
we don't I mean we don't really
understand quite why but it seems like
there is a developmental phenotype
that's implicated here so we're going to
look into that in a minute right I just
want to hear sort of show you what some
of these pictures look like and this is
a tiny fraction of what is really a huge
hair ball inside escape but we filtered
it down so you could kind of see this
and you can make node sorry edge weights
proportional to the number of shortest
paths that go between them the pathway
nodes in blue
here not all of them are high degree
right some of them are lower degree and
actually this is probably more high
degree ones than you would normally see
in a subset of a graph it's just did I
don't know I'm still not sufficiently
fluent cytoscape to slice these up as
well as I should be but but you can
certainly see how these could be
mediating the signal between the disease
nodes in red and the differential
Express nodes in green so the pathway
knows are the notes that you're
predicting based on this info the
pathway nodes are the ones that have
high between a high between this group
centrality for significantly high
between this group centrally than the
original differentially expressed you I
mean how you were Thanks yeah you are
learning which pathways are mediating
this signal okay but cool buddy nation
is based on know my validation is based
on experiment right so well we're
getting to it I mean so so the
experiment a trait so we're still
working on the experiments but that's
that's where it's coming from um no so
I'm not doing functional enrichment cuz
these are pathways chosen to be you know
in a gene set so they're going to be
enriched for that gain set right this is
how we're picking them um
what's the role of the red and the green
is in the formulation yes so these are
disease genes that are is like gos
associated genes with disease or some
animal models predicts that their
disease related um are the red ones and
the green ones i know i shouldn't have
used red and green but actually it
wasn't my choice the green ones are
differentially expressed in those data
sets i was showing yeah right and the
pathways are input as well but we select
the ones that are considered significant
and you're looking not on General
centrality box at writing in respect to
connecting their identity connecting the
red and the green and Pat yeah pathways
sensuality of the group connecting the
red and the green / shortest paths that
will connect wii and looking for those
blues that will connect those with each
other yeah and that will do some more
significantly to other things and the
point of that is to find mediators and
some of the some of the stories I've
been trying to sort of say are showing
you that there is some suggested
evidence in the literature confirming
this and we're doing experiments now to
actually try to validate things more
directly so the thing I wanted to talk
about in the last few minutes is that
this this temporal dysregulation right
this developmental disregard that then
focused on looking at developmental
districts pression actually on a bunch
of other data sets so I'm just going to
give you the tip of the iceberg on the
bronchopulmonary dysplasia data but
basically there are lots of algorithms
out there for time series analysis of
gene expression and finding things that
are differentially expressed over time
most of them have the sort of following
paradigm right you take a gene you take
some control data you fit a model of
some kind to that genes expression in
the controls you fit another model to
that genes expression in the
these you compare the two models and if
they're different enough you say the
gene is differentially expressed right
there are any number of variations on
this theme we're looking at this in a
slightly different way we're not we're
building on in one model so it's an
outlier detection approach and we're not
building a model of genes we're actually
building a model of age or time right so
the idea here is if there is a pathway
that is regulated with development then
it might be possible for us to predict
age from expression of the genes in that
pathway right so this is a set of genes
related to a function and we're going to
try to predict age if it works well in
the controls if we get a good model
where the errors aren't too large then
we're going to use that same model to
predict in the disease state and again
for some of these pathways it may be the
same in the controls and the disease and
for some this age-related developmental
products pression profile may be
disrupted in disease and so we're gonna
see this by basically measuring the
probability of the errors and disease to
errors and controls or we actually do
this we fit a normal distribution to
these errors which turns out to fit
reasonably well and we use it to predict
probabilities in both cases and again we
do significance assessment by scrambling
the sample labels in kind of the obvious
way and this is actually FDR adjusted so
I'm I'm pretty confident the things that
show up is being significant are really
significant um when you do this with
bronchopulmonary dysplasia data right so
before we were just looking at sort of
either genes that are differentially
expressed in BPD you know no respect to
time and disease genes have nothing to
do with expression and pathways that
have nothing to do with either of those
right but now we're going to look at the
time series data as as way of predicting
over time and what we see is one of the
top hits in BPD is vasculogenesis right
we can build a pretty good model of age
in the controls not such a good model
it's very dysregulated in
zzz right and one thing I point I want
to sort of emphasize here is that um yes
this is the same expression data set as
the other one but we're looking at in a
very different way and the genes in this
set which comes from the gene ontology
and the genes in this set which comes
from mammalian phenotype ontology are
ninety percent different right so we're
looking at actually pretty different
sets of genes it's not totally
independent but it's pretty independent
and it's a different way of looking at
things we see differential expression of
vascular Genesis we also see not as
significant but the bone ossification
pathway again very different gene sets
almost ninety two percent different
between the ossification one from the
MPO and from this right and so the last
point I think I want to make about all
of this is that this is starting to shed
some light on the role of vascular
genesis in BPD so there is this huge
battle going on among neonatologist
basically looking at right it's it's
known that there are problems in
vascular development in bronchopulmonary
dysplasia or an infant to get it it is
not known whether that's a cause or
consequence of the disorder and people
are slinging mud at each other back and
forth and literature about this right
but we're actually seeing some signs of
this even in infant or five days old now
you could still say that's a consequence
even though they can't be diagnosed with
a disorder for another month or two
maybe they're still having they have
something going on it's consequential
we're going to try to look-look title if
we are now getting data we just did some
RNA seek on expression from newborns and
cord blood and we're going to try and
validate this and several of the other
hypotheses that seem to be held you know
supported from literature in our own
models that's kind of what we're doing
with this again this is you know ongoing
work but I think the point is you can
actually identify mediating pathways
some that have been validated elsewhere
using this notion of pathway sensuality
and you can learn something about how
disease works and we've been finding
things that people have suggested as
therapeutic targets so maybe we
find more of them but verification
absolutely is something that we have to
continue to work on and you know we're
doing those experiments and so the
upshot of all of this is I do when I
really thank everybody who is involved
in this the pathway centrality stuff was
mostly work of jisu park was one of my
grad students the temporal modeling
thing is Michael Petrus there's another
of my grad students and I thank Ben and
Lenore and everybody else is in this
room and Diana Bianchi is the genetic
and neonatal geneticist who leads a
group called the mother-infant research
institute of Tufts Medical Center and
there are several doctors there who have
been working on and fellows and what
various other people have been working
on this stuff so I really want to thank
them none of this stuff is published yet
what is published is the work that it's
built on the annotation related to
development on the disease and
development work and some work on
anomaly detection so I wanted to put
those references up there as well and
thank you for so I didn't understand how
you do the age prediction yeah okay good
i glossed over there a little bit um
where did i do the air th prediction ok
so that's a good point right so this is
some kind of predictive model we
actually looked at a whole bunch of
predictive models but relatively simple
ones since we're looking for something
linear the one that seems to work well
and not over fit as partial least
squares regression right so we build a
regret is basically just a regression
model no it's the set of genes in the
pathway at age right so I definitely
glossing over a lot of stuff here but um
so we have a whole bunch of jeans and a
pathway or a set and we're gonna use
those as a tan sage predictors and we
did try I know we don't know we know
that we just predict age for that that
particular
yes this is expression yeah right but I
mean in some cases we can't predict age
from pathway at all and then we're not
going to do this right we're not going
to consider we don't even we don't even
bother scoring its performance on the
dizzies state if it doesn't do well in
the controls right so there are lots of
pathways that have nothing to do with
the value know whose expression is not
related to development we don't care
about them right we just care about the
ones where it's good are there any are
there any disease cases where is there a
disease where that pathway that we had a
good model for suddenly breaks down
right and this is something we've used
in this anomaly detection paradigm is
this idea of finding you know just
learning from one in one sided examples
and looking and seeing where that model
fails and that seems to have served as
well here as well
yeah so in the beep actually said this
is again this is a bigger study that
isn't as network key so I didn't spend
as much time on it um the BPD data the
ages are from about 25 weeks I mean
basically from you know whatever the
young youngest sort of viability in the
study was up to about 32 beyond about 32
weeks they're not sufficiently premature
to be likely have these complications so
we don't include them but we have also
looked at this kind of model in kids
with autism up to age 18 or so we've
looked at it actually in adults with
Huntington's disease week and you know
you can see age of onset and predict age
even in cases where they haven't shown
symptoms of the disease yet you can
identify if they're outliers so we can
use it for a lot of different things um
but yeah so one so if I understand
correctly you're taking every gene in
the pathway that gene gets some
coefficient to break age and that's how
you build the model is that right more
or less oh we're taking out yeah all of
them together and yeah and then a
follow-up question are there any cases
where in the disease you can predict age
but in controls you're unable to that's
a great question I don't know if we've
looked at that but offhand I don't think
so
I have not seen anything that looks like
we could look that more systematically
right yeah technically breaks down what
I would love to see and that happens
occasionally let's see if I can this is
you know to see just a real a line that
just shifts right we're seeing things
that are older or younger looking it's
usually not that clean it usually goes
from ordered to disordered more than
ordered to shift it low but um you know
we have only looked a few data sets so
we'll keep looking yeah age in weeks
this is agent this is just a gestational
age or i should say but maybe weeks post
conception is the right way to call that
because there they've been born but its
aging weeks yeah yeah and this is again
this is sort of bend this is a data
that's been by age from if they give you
a week they don't give you a week in
three days or something so again when
you have on the autism data set we
actually had a version of it where we
had very fine resolution ages but the
version we're using it to publish is the
published version and therefore doesn't
have that data and you can see you know
the discretization her to a little bit
but not that much
how likely you are to get something like
this have Brenda um well that's why we
did the scrambles right so these are all
come yeah so we look through all the
different pathways but we also compared
them to cases where we scrambled the
class labels so we say this patient has
BPD and this patient doesn't at random
and then build it build the same model
and yeah you get nothing out when you do
that too very significant now right i
mean so these are all compared to a
bunch of runs of that and then adjusted
for multiple testing so these are
right there are there are diseases where
that we're like there's just nothing
right so if you look at his ease and
there isn't a good model and of
development in the expression data and I
actually thought that would happen with
the Huntington's data I'm really
surprised that we found something um but
you know my my student was just looking
at it and said oh look what I found so
okay things don't I get thank you